ja voorzitter
er zijn Tal van aannames die hier ook vandaag
in de kamer
gedaan worden
ik HEB mevrouw Becker er even op aangesproken
dat zij de aanname deed
dat die kinderen die aan het kinkhoest zijn overleden
dat die allemaal ongevaccineerd waren
dat is 1 aanname
we zien dat dit ook in de media
in Tal van gekleurde berichten
wordt overgenomen
en de staatssecretaris heeft het nu over
het toevoegen
van 1 waarschuwing onder bepaalde berichten
waar we mee te maken hebben ook voor 1 democratie
is dat
er niet alleen zo'n waarschuwing onder komt te staan
maar dat wij dat ook
video's en bijdragen van ons van internet worden
verwijderd bijvoorbeeld toen ik hier in de kamer
ervoor waarschuwde dat
de coronavaccins transmissie niet voorkomen
toen werd dat van internet verwijderd
omdat dat desinformatie zou zijn
na 1 paar maanden later
moest schoorvoetend worden toegegeven dat inderdaad
die vaccins
geen transmissie voorkomen en dus dat dat het hele
frame je doet het voor 1 ander
desinformatie was